[Music]
our economy or Tartu or hunger a
district is home to over six thousand
businesses and we have a highly skilled
labor market however over 40% of our
working population currently work
outside our district around
three-quarters of those would prefer to
work locally as suitable work was
available of the 460 hectares of land
currently zones of business around 100
of that is underutilized or evasive
are we providing the right opportunities
of businesses and right location we need
to consider what type of environments
large employers are looking for while
also making Waimakariri a place where
talented people want to learn a district
our future Waimakariri 2,048 aims to
more carefully manage business
activities in rural and residential area
to minimize adverse effects on
neighboring communities increase support
for attracting new business to the
district in the creation of more local
drivers in closely monitored land
development in business trends so we can
respond quickly if demand and
preferences change
so what do you think let us know your
thoughts in find out more about the
district development strategy at
Waimakariri gibt dot MP
you